all right this thing on there's the
camera okay so this episode is about how
to make the ultimate sure they're a
great standalone video-chatting devices
like the Facebook portal or the Amazon
echo show but you don't need to spend
money on those or leave the house to get
ready step 1 get an old tablet or phone
if these old devices are slow reset the
whole thing to factory settings and
install the latest operating system if
the battery's old just keep it plugged
in you can buy an extra long charging
cable if you need some wiggle room 10
feet every 110 feet of lightning cable
or get an extension cord you don't have
an old tablet buy a new one like the
lowest end iPod or a Samsung Galaxy Tab
a step to make a homemade stand stop
propping up your devices with random
things from around the house and instead
use things from around the house that
really work
you could try a wire hanger with it haha
[Music]
this a little bit back alright that's
looking good and then this is a little
lip for the iPad in the front it doesn't
look like much but check it out
or you could try the cardboard box
method and these days you want to
disinfect measure a rectangle that's
about 25 centimeters by 20 centimeters
[Music]
then measure 11 centimeters across then
draw some diagonal lines like so and
then do like so or you could try the egg
[Music]
or you could try to let go method which
my toddler is very confused by the
beauty of all these is you can place
these in different areas around the
house step 3 install your video chat
software of choice my go-to is FaceTime
which is already built into your iPad or
iPhone but of course there's also zoom
house-party Google Hangouts all of those
apps still worked on this 2012 iPad that
only supports iOS 10 though some
features were limited doesn't matter
they all work with this great new scam
[Music]
what just happened